I am assuming you already
know about Hadoop a bit.
So, here's just a brief summary.
Your basic Hadoop cluster
consists of a name node.
A secondary name node, resource
manager and one or more data nodes.
I'll go through what each
of these does in a bit.
The type of node is determined by the
Hadoop daemon running on the machine.
These dudes here.
Daemons are just programs
that run in the background.
They handle all sorts of fun stuff like,
communication across a cluster.
They track jobs and
resources and run MapReduce code.
When they load data under the cluster,
the files are split the blocks,
then typically replicated
across the data nodes.
So if a data node dies,
your data is still around somewhere.
MapReduce and other tools,
run in parallel on the data nodes.
This increases the effective
computational speed.
The NameNode stores
metadata about the blocks.
It stores it in a file called .fsimage.
The NameNode stores metadata about
the blocks in a file called .fsimage.
Metadata is data about the data.
In this case, which block is
stored on which data node.
It's like an address book for
the blocks.
The secondary name node logs
edits to the file system.
changes to theFS image,
which are then used to update
the file on the name node.
It's actually a fairly,
poorly named though.
The finger name node stores only edits,
not the actual FS image file.
So the name node dyes,
the block Metadata is all gone.
The resource manager is called the YARN
for yet another resource negotiator.
It allocates resources like C.P.U.
and memory to applications
running on the cluster.
You run all the daemons on one machine.
It's called pseudo-distributed mode.
This is how I set up my computer when
I'm working on MapReduce programs.
In this lesson, you're going to
build a cluster with one machine
running the name node,
the secondary name node, and Yarn.
The rest of the cluster
will be three data nodes.
Let's get started
deploying your cluster.